every September my f my wife and I send
an email out to the family here's what
our travel plans are going to be for
Thanksgiving and Christmas and it's
usually based on a conversation my wife
and I have what's the tra what's my
travel season been like what's her
writing season been like what's our kids
like schedule's been like and what's our
financial situation this year like what
are we going to do but we get to pick
that and then if my mom decides to get
super angry and mad she's a grown woman
she gets to do
that that's her Choice that's not I
can't fix that for her and by the way I
don't think this has to be some big
announcement some big grandiose talk I
think it's hey we're not traveling this
year for the holidays we'll FaceTime in
and we're really going to miss you